[Musica]
wow quante persone laura conoscono te la pau
l'aiuto di reig è super gratuito
tutto bene a 2 e sicuramente squadra
saranno che il futuro costringerà la paura
quale parte della cultura è se non il
cultura del futuro più adatto prima di
tutto bene questa presentazione e I
Ero più che posato portato in giro
cultura e quella non scienza
la gastronomia ha lavorato per il cibo del futuro
istituire una bologna a cura di
trasformare la capra usa il
fermentazioni e attraverso l'aiuto
del microrganismo di due contano quelli
prodotti con un alto valore e un alto
di valore
Dico ok ha lavorato con la capra in cui la capra
parte anche se le impostazioni cultura del file generano a
impatto el chivo è un linguaggio comune e
ata bolatti ragazza pianoforte tutti par
chiama questo quella linea non in importi e
mostrarti la cultura o meno la tua ragazza pianista
tweet e ci siamo sentiti da quella musica il
silenzio e soprattutto è la capra è
Bene
abbiamo perso il traffico che la capra
michele chimú cultura lingua che mangio a
capra genera un impatto sui modelli il
la nostra mentalità da che parte stava andando
per raccontare in estrema sintesi l'aneddoto
il costo in tutto ruota intorno a mio cugino
jorn lo stesso in italia suono spagnolo
suonato in tocoa profilo cinese molto utile di
master e al cinema sono solo rime tocoa
e principe e prigioni abbiamo fatto il tuo
mettiamo il nostro becco l'antipasto
realizzazione di un prototipo di prodotto
e fermentato che stavamo abilitando
al nostro laboratorio come pubblicato in
facebook ma promuoverlo è giusto che
Questo commento di un signore è che questi dati
feedback di mio cugino
questi signori lo mettiamo a chiamare
antonio come quello che antonio de la costa
di quello che ti indossa mamma antonio mediz
costi tecnici e negativi e tu costi
cose moderne e non quello che sono
distruggere un pool per l'autenticità non lo fa
è la tradizione italiana wow bravos
cugino ha lavorato al top
Ho pensato a 24 ore per risponderti
e stagno malvagio perché la forza sarà
molto progressista che questo venerdì quindi sì
può rispondere il vescovo attenzione
istituto gratuito gratuito per feedback
bene capire la tua delle illusioni
e loro uno spagnolo amo la capra
Gli spagnoli e si dice difendono la tradizione
Lo spagnolo per quanto difendo che amo
la tradizione italiana ma mi permetta di diff
art una richiesta esattamente con l'
tradizione che ti distingua così tanto che il
la tradizione mi pone esattamente quando
inizia quando il pomodoro è finito tutto
la america o da quando la basilica
su tutta l'India perché quel pt al
fine la capra non ha scommesso la capra i dati
se coltivate in modo sostenibile
sostenibile con l'ambiente con oggi il
persona società sostenibile in un certo senso
economico un ostinato mapfre cuuelo
La capra
eddie tutti nel post o dove cresce
Gli dico di tenerlo, semplicemente mi offro
ingredienti locali lo hanno trasformato
attraverso la storia perché
fermentazione in fallimenti di setenil
di anefa non in cui l'inventò e I
l'applicazione è con la coscienza di oggi
e con la consapevolezza dell'agenzia questo
è il risultato che c'è già anche la mamma
la mia intenzione è sfruttarne la pendenza
Tradizione italiana perché alla fine lo è stata
quello che avevamo capire è che avevamo
fare e innovazione e oggi e vedere
tradizione e noccioline e per me non più
a york non c'è tradizione
finito scoperto come un modo di
mantieni il ritardo come tutti da te
aspetta che il bambino prediletto
formato umami al vento e al mondo forzato
governo continuerà a forgiare questo godimento
ogni estremità la capra evita e la capra dentro
il nostro sostentamento il creatore di energia
e la capra è sociale
perché leggiamo che una lingua comune è alta
volato e abbiamo cambiato le persone di michele
la capra anche se un impatto economico e
entrambi il problema è che non si allinea
con l'impatto ambientale che siamo
generando questa posizione che avevamo
continuerà a innovare e trasformare
la nostra mentalità fornisce la posizione
impatto economico non con un milione
impatti sociali e ambientali
finalmente la capra scultura più adatta
inizio anche se sono rimasto più di una cosa di
cultura senza cultura cultura cultura
cultura del futuro che ha sviluppato con il
capra e ai piedi gatti di auto moto
velo ma che dire della cultura
Stavo cercando questa definizione e cugino di
salva il dizionario dei fosfati a
alimentazione e chiudere in un unico statico se lo è
la cultura baleato è una chiusura di
la mentalità di encardin è in un tempo
in uno spazio finito
Imparerò questa definizione in
tre variabili mentalità spazio temporale
rilievo frazione una picola di
questioni
tra il tempo avanza lo spazio
trasformarsi in regine dice la mentalità
l'est non si trasforma in quella diffamazione
ora partiremo per dare il destino a
ambiente erboso circostante
cresce lo stesso a reggio emilia cambia il
bambino non avevano provato diversi al tri
modalità e ora leggiamo che domani si intrufola
Herba produce un latte macchiato diverso e il vento va
per mille annunci ai testi più senza
base c'è un germoglio da innovare è facile
da milioni a 320 forze diverse e lunatiche lo faranno
lo spazio cambia con l'azione del tempo
la nostra mentalità sarà però adattata
alla fine con tutto metti l'unica cosa che
tornato dirò è che dovremmo creare il
impatto attraverso il tuo manager
abbiamo dovuto cambiare il pianoforte per il nostro
mentalità antonio non uso se la
capita no no no niente più disposto ma
ma in un più grande e marito lottare
minuto anche in panchina a proprio agio
occasione di incontrarlo ma
importante è che se il nuovo bene entra
azioni che non sono se dovessimo provare
dietro ci metto il divertimento perché l'unico
il modo per arrivare al futuro è per tutti
coloriamo il calicò alla fine la capra e
cultura nella cultura il futuro karachi
[Applausi]
Y
[Musica]